one three minus five and eight this is
just a row of four numbers and this can
be represented in different ways we can
write it as an array of numbers
horizontally like this or we can write
it as an array of numbers vertically
like this the first part as you can see
has one row and four columns and the
second part has four rows and one column
there is another way in which we can
write the four numbers the first two
numbers in the first row and the last
two numbers in the second row all these
three things you see here are called
matrices each of these is a matrix just
an arrangement of rows and columns but
how do we properly define it we can say
that a matrix is a rectangular
arrangement but a rectangular
arrangement of what it can be anything
numbers letters are the characters
anything a matrix is made up of rows and
columns the first matrix has one row and
four columns the second one has four
rows and one column and what about the
third one it has two rows and two
columns so a matrix is just a
rectangular arrangement of rows and
columns but there is one important
condition we need to keep in mind each
row needs to have equal number of
elements for instance in the second
Matrix each row has one element and in
the third matrix each row has two
elements and each column also needs to
have equal number of elements in the
first matrix each column has one element
the second Matrix has just one column so
it doesn't matter and in the third one
each column has two elements so a matrix
is a rectangular arrangement of rows and
columns in which each row has equal
number of elements and each column as
well has equal number of elements so is
this a matrix elements a and B in the
first row and element C and D in the
second it is a rectangular arrangement
each row has two elements and each
column has two elements it is a May
Drix and these three are also matrices
okay what about this one with three
elements is it a matrix the first row
has two elements but the second one just
has one element so it is not a matrix
what about this one with five elements
the number of elements in each of the
columns is not the same it's two one and
two and this as well is not a matrix so
this is the definition a rectangular
arrangement of rows and columns in which
each row should have equal number of
elements and each column as well should
have equal number of elements